una década de caos entre 2011 y 2021
libia ha caído en una crisis
multidimensional sin precedentes de
entrada en el plano político cuando cayó
muamar gadafi tras 40 años en el poder
distintas milicias se disputaron el
control del país se organizaron
elecciones en 2012 y 2014 pero fracasó
el objetivo de constituir un gobierno
estable mientras el estado quedaba
partido en dos después de años de
conflictos entre el este y el oeste a
principios de 2021 la onu designó un
nuevo ejecutivo interino que tiene la
misión de conducir a libia a la primera
elección presidencial de su historia el
próximo 24 de diciembre concurren varios
candidatos potenciales el antiguo
ministro de interior fathi bachagha el
militar califa adaptar comandante en
jefe del ejército nacional libio hombre
fuerte del ala este del país y seif
al-islam gadafi cuyo retrato cuelga con
orgullo al lado del del guía supremo su
padre en la entrada de la localidad de
bani walid en este bastión del gadafismo
los habitantes no esconden la nostalgia
la revuelta de 2011 solo nos ha traído
guerras desolación división e
injerencias y ataques contra la
soberanía de nuestro país
fuimos fieles a nuestro guía muamar
gadafi y seremos fieles a seif al-islam
en libia la crisis también es
securitaria tras la intervención de la
otan en el territorio quedó controlado
por distintos grupos armados y más de
20.000 mercenarios extranjeros combaten
en el país según la onu una presencia
que ha contribuido a obstaculizar el
desarrollo de la soberanía nacional
libia